este encuentro en Munich es considerado
por muchísimos como el principal foro
mundial para debatir la política de
seguridad internacional verdad qué
oportunidad cree usted que representa
para Ucrania estar en el centro del
encuentro podría marcar una diferencia
para kiev quizás
en realidad no creo que que va a
presentar nuevas oportunidades en
términos de negociación Pero sí va a dar
oportunidades para mostrar solidaridad
para mostrar Unión Y eso han logrado en
realidad los diferentes países de la
otan los debates que sí hubo eran más de
carácter técnico Por ejemplo si uno
debería enviar bombas de racimo a
Ucrania lo que está pidiendo pero
Alemania se está oponiendo por razones
legales Así que estas son en este
momento son preguntas son cuestiones más
de carácter técnico y el drama
caracterizó por ejemplo la iteración
anterior de la conferencia de seguridad
se acabó todos apoyan a Ucrania
Obviamente con diferentes
niveles de intensidad para decirlo así y
con diferentes ideas sobre cómo va a
resultar la situación en Europa Oriental
pero en general se mostró una Unión
relativamente sólida es cierto se ha
mostrado más cuestión como viene usted
dice en esta línea hemos escuchado en la
conferencia al momento líderes de alto
nivel no por ejemplo la vicepresidenta
de Estados Unidos kamala Harris acusando
a Rusia de crímenes de lesa humanidad
Vimos a Úrsula bounder Legend pidiendo
acelerar como decíamos la producción de
municiones para quién qué
pronunciamientos considera usted al
momento que se destacan
yo destacaría definitivamente lo ya
mencionado de la vicepresidenta y
también de Anthony quienes dijeron que
Rusia obviamente cometió como estado
crímenes de lesa humanidad lo que podría
abrir el camino a una prosecución
jurídica de esos crímenes posiblemente
en un tribunal
especial o hasta en el Corte Penal
Internacional eso eso todavía es para
definir pero es un tiene un impacto
considerable porque realmente se está
calificando el comportamiento de Rusia
como estado como criminal como
delincuencia internacional lo que en
realidad
endurece y fortifica el posicionamiento
de la principal potencia occidental en
este compite falta tan solo una semana
para que se cumpla un año de la invasión
de Rusia a Ucrania es imposible
prácticamente por supuesto saber cómo
continuarán Y cómo avanzará el conflicto
Pero hay ya algunos lineamientos quizás
que se puedan vislumbrar con respecto a
cómo continuará el conflicto
básicamente lo que estamos viendo en
este momento y coinciden todos los
expertos También acá en la conferencia
de seguridad coinciden los expertos que
normalmente tienen distintas opiniones
que la ofensiva rusa que estamos
observando en estos momentos es débil
que Rusia no ha podido en gran medida no
ha podido reconstituir sus fuerzas
militares para pues lograr cualquier
tipo de capacidad para una ofensiva de
de guerra mecanizada no en realidad lo
que estamos viendo otra vez son olas
humanas con pérdidas muy muy graves
Rusia está perdiendo más que mil
soldados cada día así que en realidad
uno puede detectar cierto optimismo
entre los diferentes expertos y
tomadores de Decisiones Con quienes
conversé
pero también cierta incertidumbre sobre
cómo exactamente va a terminar Cómo
logramos después Un nuevo orden de paz
en Europa en Europa Oriental y cómo se
va a aportar por ejemplo china en esta
situación Cómo va a seguir la situación
la
la incipiente alianza entre China y
Rusia Cómo se va a desarrollar
hay mucha incertidumbre con respecto al